d'une halle ferroviaire il n'en reste
que la charpente métallique dans sa
réhabilitation du quartier des chantiers
la mairie de versailles a trouvé en
nature et découvertes
une enseigne spécialisée dans les
produits de bien-être et devient avec la
nature fondée en 1990 l'entreprise
idéale pour s'y installer
pas question pour autant de détruire ces
vestiges du passé et j'ai donc décidé
très tôt de prendre deux bâtiments tel
qu'il était de construire un bâtiment en
bois qui viennent le confort t il
quelque chose qu'ils demanderaient et
pour les uns vieux bâtiments dans la
commune en tant qu' une béquille avec un
nouveau matériau le clt comparable un
contreplaqué plus épais il est composé
de pins blancs du nord et permet de
construire des bâtiments de grande
hauteur
plus de 3000 mètres carrés sur trois
étages en bois pour un effet très nature
avec également des panneaux
photovoltaïques sur le toit
on est dans la grande tradition de l'adn
de nature à découvert c'est à dire
l'écologie la nature et d'écologie pas
d'accord ce bâtiment est totalement
écologique
et puis derrière nous avons dans la
chance d'avoir des jardins qui nous en a
été donnée en concession par la ville de
versailles pour faire d un potager en
permaculture car la fondation nature et
découvertes installe avec son siège un
jardin permaculture une aubaine pour le
maire de versailles qui souhaitait
installer un potager dans sa ville mais
manquer de financements
on a trop souffert des six villes
dortoirs côté de paris ici c'est une
ville avec son urbanité avec sa
complexité
et aujourd'hui on montre que à côté de
ce coeur de ville il peut y avoir des
jardins les travaux vont se poursuivre
jusqu'au printemps 2010 9 et
l'entreprise espère s'y installer au
mois de mai